Цей момент Олена Захаренко не забуде ніколи. Для неї було непросто
зустрітися з Юрієм Гаравським, який зізнався в співучасті у вбивстві її батька.
Мені це потрібно було зробити - не тільки для моєї родини, але й для інших людей.
Я зробила це для того, аби відкрити світу очі про те, що коїться у Білорусі.
Після зустрічі в Олени не залишилося сумнівів у тому, що Гаравський сказав правду.
Слідчий комітет Білорусі після виходу фільму Deutsche Welle "Вбивства критиків Лукашенко"
відновив розслідування за фактом зникнення колишнього голови МВС Юрія Захаренка.
Але через три місяці знову призупинив його - через неможливість встановити особу звинуваченого.
За нинішньої влади в нас немає сумнівів, що не буде жодної правди або достовірної інформації про те, що сталося.
Юрій Захаренко, ще на посаді очільника МВС у середині 90-х
звинувачував Олександра Лукашенка в корупції. У свою чергу, Лукашенко
обвинуватив у корупції Захаренка - і відправив його у відставку.
Захаренко пішов в опозицію. На цих кадрах видно, як він виступив проти затримання опозиціонера Віктора Гончара.
Кілька місяців потому безслідно зникли і Захаренко, і Гончар.
За справою про зникнення ексдепутата Гончара вже більше 20 років стежать у комітеті Міжпарламентського союзу з прав парламентаріїв.
У жовтні в Женеві заслухали свідчення Гаравського.
Тепер, з урахуванням останньої інформації, що була передана комітету
на слуханнях за участі пана Гаравського, комітет ще більше переконаний у тому,
що за всі ці роки білоруські органи влади не провели серйозного розслідування.
І все це в сукупності дозволяє комітету з великою ймовірністю казати про те,
що за цим висновком можуть стояти високопоставлені чиновники Білорусі.
Сам Юрій Гаравський вже два роки перебуває у Швейцарії, де він попросив притулку й чекає на рішення.
Я не можу ніяк прокоментувати його подальшу долю, через те, що ці люди знищили нашу долю і долі інших білорусів.
Після зникнення батька Олена разом із сином, сестрою і матір'ю виїхала до Німеччини,
де вони отримали політичний притулок. У Білорусі залишилась бабуся Олени, мати Юрія Захаренка.
Олена: Ось вже два роки, бабусю, як ми тебе не бачимо. Матеріальні можливості маленькі, тому чуємо тебе нечасто.
Хотілося б колись, звичайно, зустрітися з тобою, побачити твій будинок...
- А де твій дідусь, скажи?
- Вкрали.
- А хто?
- Розбійники.
Наприкінці 90-х Юрій Захаренко був одним із лідерів протестного руху.
Багато хто тоді вимагав відставки Олександра Лукашенка.
Понад 20 років потому - ті самі вимоги протестувальників на вулицях Мінська.
Одна ідея: звільнення країни від диктатури.
Нині ми бачимо нове покоління, яке бачить вікно в Європу, яке бачить інші цінності, знає, що таке правова держава.
Те, що відбувалося у 90-ті, і те, що відбувається зараз, розділяти неможливо.
Тоді вони знищували людей приховано. Зараз роблять це відкрито.
Вбивають, саджають у в'язниці. Події, до яких ми зараз прийшли, це наслідки минулих років.
Все це сталося від безкарності злочинців.
Олена Захаренко вважає, що на Олександра Лукашенка чекає доля або Януковича, або Каддафі.
Свою народну любов він би побачив, якби вийшов на майдан до людей без своїх охоронців.
Його люди просто розірвали б від великої любові...
Скільки родин втратили своїх дітей? Скільки родин страждають від того, що їхні діти перебувають у в'язницях?
Вони не знають, чи вийдуть вони колись на свободу. Вони бояться вийти на вулицю, аби їх не затримали, знищили,
вбили, зґвалтували. Там же свавілля правове коїться.
На думку Олени, у багатьох білорусів нині відкрились очі на систему, жертвою якої вона та її родина стали понад 20 років тому.
Голос за кадром: "Онук Юрія Захаренка дуже схожий на діда.
Під час зйомки Юрій Миколайович сказав: ось виросте онук, подивиться на діда
і захоче з'їздити на його могилку вирвати кропиву. Де могила Юрія Захаренка, не знає ніхто,
окрім тих, хто вбив його".
Зараз онуку Юрія Захаренка - 22. Ані він, ані його мати після того, як залишили Білорусь у 2000-му році, не були там - навіть на похороні бабусі.
Я зобов'язана приїхати в Білорусь, щоб проститися з моїми близькими, яких я не змогла поховати.
Я маю прийти на місце поховання мого батька. Він заслужив, щоб йому поставили пам'ятник.
У мене є від Гаравського графік, де це все відбулося.
Гаравський: Ось на цій дорозі було вбито вашого батька.
Я маю попрощатися зі своєю землею. Людина, яка не попрощалася зі своїм минулим, не може дивитися в майбутнє.
Олена сподівається, що найближчим часом попрощатись із темним минулим вдасться не лише їй, але й її рідній країні - Білорусі.